[Music]
on this sunday night desperate escape
the evacuation of civilians from a steel
plant in mariupol is finally underway as
war-torn ukraine receives a surprise
visit from a top u.s official our
commitment is to be there for you
archbishop apology i am more sorry than
i can say the head of the anglican
church makes an historic statement to
sunday mass in saskatchewan the ottawa
bikers rally rolls to a close as police
investigate a hate crime targeting the
protesters plus flower power
thousands of hockey fans gather in
montreal to say goodbye to gila fleur
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight
jeff semple
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with a sliver of rare good
news from ukraine some of the civilians
who were trapped for weeks inside a
marijuana steel plant have finally been
evacuated take a look at this new video
that provides a rare look inside one of
the plants bunkers it was reportedly
recorded last week and shows families
with young children toddlers wearing
diapers made of cellophane with little
food or drinking water
so far around 100 civilians have escaped
but 100 000 more remain trapped inside
that besieged city jennifer johnson has
more on the evacuation effort and a
surprise visit to the ukrainian capital
evacuations are underway for some
ukrainians trapped inside a mario pole
steel plan russian vehicles are
escorting buses for safe passage in a
deal negotiated by the united nations
an estimated three thousand soldiers and
civilians have been sheltering in the
compound for weeks while russian forces
reduce the port city to rubble time is
critical it goes without saying that in
places like mario poll that haven't been
reached by meaningful humanitarian
assistance in two months where you have
people dying of starvation of
dehydration i mean those are the the
true horrors that are being perpetrated
right now the desperate effort comes as
u.s house speaker nancy pelosi and a
small congressional delegation made a
surprise trip to keith nice to meet you
and met with ukrainian president
vladimir zelinski as a show of america's
unflinching support america stands with
ukraine
we stand with ukraine until victory is
won zielinski thanked pelosi for the
billions america has sent as she pledged
to get u.s president joe biden's latest
33 billion aid package passed quickly
through congress lawmakers also promised
more punishing sanctions against russian
president vladimir putin there is
nowhere for him to go we're going to
continue to he putin surrenders russian
forces continue to attack ukraine in the
south and east
more missile attacks hit odessa sunday
but the u.s canada and their nato allies
believe ukraine can win this war if it
gets the military firepower it needs
still the humanitarian toll has been
unbearable
angelina jolie a special envoy with the
united nations refugee agency visited
displaced children now living at a levee
railway station they must be in
in shock you know i know how trauma
affects children
the resilience of the ukrainian people
was also on display as many visited
cemeteries marking the orthodox
christian day of the dead they honored
the military dead despite air raid
sirens and warnings to stay home
this woman lost her husband in the war
he died so we could breathe and carry on
living she said as russia's war in
ukraine begins another month
jennifer johnson global news washington
a shipment of aid sent to ukraine by a
group from alberta has reportedly been
hijacked the volunteers say several
trucks were transporting the supplies in
ukraine when they came under attack two
of the truck drivers a pole and a
ukrainian were killed heather yorks west
has the details
thank you very much it was a passion
project spearheaded by two former
alberta politicians with deep personal
ties to ukraine
former premier ed stalmak who is of
ukrainian descent and former deputy
premier thomas lukaszek who came to
canada as a polish refugee i remember
waking up with tanks and cannons and
armored vehicles in front of our
apartment in the indiana poland
complements of the soviet union
within weeks of russia's invasion and
with the support of people from across
western canada the group collected and
shipped more than 300 tons of
much-needed aid the medical supplies
search and rescue equipment and personal
care items filled two warehouses before
it was sent to the region by both air
and sea most of our items end up
somewhere in poland and then delivered
in minivans and passenger vehicles
um to specific locations to hospitals
medical clinics to shelters orphanages
but the journeys to those towns and
cities hardest hit in the eastern part
of ukraine can be perilous and on
saturday lukaszic was forced to deliver
tragic news a couple days ago we lost a
couple of drivers
one
polish one ukrainian national there were
three one manage thankfully to escape i
can't share
the exact circumstances but they were
intercepted two were killed
paul hughes knows this risk firsthand
the former canadian soldier from calgary
has been in ukraine since march
completing 50 aid delivery missions
across the country so far predominantly
medical aid and food
and shelter-related supplies some of
these missions are three-day missions
like it's
so the road system here is
very challenging
despite the danger lukaszic says most of
the aid collected in alberta has been
able to get to those in need thanks to
the heroism of these drivers and there's
no other way to describe it but more
than two months into fighting the calls
for help are only growing louder the
kazakhstan is now focusing on raising
money to purchase food and medical aid
while paul hughes is prepared to keep
making deliveries for up to another year
heather urex west global news calgary
the head of the anglican church the
archbishop of canterbury has issued an
historic apology to survivors of
canada's residential school system
during a visit to a saskatchewan first
nation this weekend the anglican church
ran about three dozen residential
schools in canada between 1820 and 1969
our nathaniel dove spoke to one survivor
and a warning some of the details in his
report are difficult to hear
tom roberts has been here many times
before it's the site of the prince
albert residential school he was forced
to attend
beating us into it
destroying our culture our way of life
and most of all
our connection with our families today
he says
it feels different
the weight i had when i went there
yesterday
is pretty well all lifted now and i feel
good the anglican church ran dozens of
schools across canada between 1820 and
1969 including the one roberts was at
on saturday he and many others told
archbishop justin welby about the
physical emotional and sexual abuse they
suffered and the top bishop of the
church of england apologized
i am sorry
i am more sorry than i can say
it is
the rawest wickedest
most terrible thing
to molest a child
while you read them the bible he said it
and all of us had tears in our eyes when
he said it
i had my wife
took a big sigh of relief in a service
sunday
the archbishop echoed his message and
that is the tragedy
of the schools of the residential
schools
the mystery of no one objecting
the mystery of no one saying this is
outrageous
roberts accepts the archbishop's apology
but says there is a long way to go to
heal the damage he wants as many healing
lodges built on reserve as there were
churches
for now though he says he can rest i'm
relieved
i'm happy
i can go home
i can sleep well at night
nathaniel dove global news
a 24-hour crisis line is available for
anyone experiencing pain or distress as
a result of their or a loved one's
residential school experience that's the
number there it's toll-free
1-800-721-0066
this weekend's rolling thunder rally has
now wrapped up in ottawa but police
there are now investigating a possible
hate crime a church where the protesters
had gathered this morning was vandalized
the words no haven for fascism were
spray painted on the front of the church
well another message said eff off
fascists no arrests have been made but
at least 10 people were arrested as part
of the protests against pandemic
restrictions and government overreach
ottawa police had ramped up their
presence ahead of the demonstration
fearing a repeat of the freedom convoy
that occupied ottawa's downtown core for
more than three weeks back in february
ontario's 43rd general election campaign
is about to get underway with an
election call expected within days ips's
polling done exclusively for global news
shows the incumbent doug ford and his
progressive conservatives with a
three-point lead ahead of stephen del
duca's liberals and a 12-point lead on
andrea horvath's ndp
the race will have major implications
for voters in ontario of course but as
our chief political correspondent david
aiken explains there could also be
consequences for canada's federal
political parties
ontario ndp leader andrea horvath visits
a toronto suburb on the eve of ontario's
election call today's may day
international workers day it's an
opportunity to reflect on how much
workers sacrifice during the pandemic
four years ago horvas party won 15 seats
in the greater toronto area most at the
expense of the provincial liberals after
thursday i will no longer be ontario's
premier who suffered their worst defeat
ever under then leader kathleen wynne it
was a defeat so bad the liberals who'd
governed for 15 years even lost official
party status
horvath can expect a stiffer fight this
time though from a liberal party trying
to resurrect itself under new leader
stephen del duca we're going to build a
province where hard work and dedication
are valued and
number respected premiere the incumbent
premier and pc party leader doug ford
will be trying to hold those middle of
the road voters who gave him a majority
in 2018. great to be here today and
i have to tell you
on june the second people have a very
clear choice but while it's ontario's
choice it's really a race for the whole
country because it affects voters in
more than one third of canada's federal
ridings the provincial election does not
exist in a vacuum there are uh many
other considerations at play here
and if ford can win back-to-back
majorities as a moderate conservative
that could influence the federal party
which of course is in the midst of a
leadership race
clearly there are elements of a
progressive conservatives a more
moderate conservative uh policy and
ethos that are resonating uh within
ontario the trudeau liberals have been
dominant in ontario in three successive
federal elections and have built three
governments on that dominance and that's
why any shift in the political geography
in that province this spring could have
a big impact on the political geography
of the country in the months ahead jeff
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
coming up the next new orleans why
quebec's premier believes the big easy
offers a hard lesson for french speakers
[Music]
chanting ghee outside the bell center in
montreal today hockey fans lined up to
pay respects to gee lafleur the habs
great died 10 days ago from lung cancer
visitation at the arena continues
tomorrow and the public national funeral
will be held tuesday morning in montreal
lefleur was 70 years old
for almost 50 years french has been the
only official language in quebec but two
newly formed political parties would
prefer the province become bilingual
both parties are planning to run
candidates in quebec's fall election
targeting ridings with large populations
of english-speaking quebecers such as
montreal but as dan specter reports
quebec's premier is pushing back
bourbon street mardi gras jazz music
many people see the state of louisiana
as a bucket list destination but quebec
premier francois lago sees it as a
cautionary tale
if quebec is bilingual
unfortunately the attraction
in north america to english will be so
strong that it will be a matter of time
before we don't speak french
in quebec and we become
louisiana
back when it was founded in 1718 new
orleans was known as nouvelle orleans
the capital of the french colony of
louisiana 300 years later its
connections to the french language are
mostly history french will always be
fragile in north america so we have to
protect french lago made the louisiana
comments in a week that saw the birth of
two new political parties in quebec who
unlike lagos coalition abner quebec
consider bilingualism in the province as
part of their core values you know
bilingualism uh you know is a bedrock
idea it's foundational to quebec one is
called the canadian party of quebec the
other is led by a former cfl player both
party leaders are trying to ride a
growing wave of anglo agitation born out
of the lego government's efforts to
strengthen legislation protecting the
french language and the sentiment that
the usually anglo-friendly liberal party
is not speaking up for the linguistic
minority anger among english speakers is
reaching heights perhaps not seen since
the 90s where now we're starting to see
similar parallels to how frustrated and
angry the community is and how much the
community feels like they're political
orphans again robert libman would know
he helped spearhead an anglo uprising in
the 90s when he founded a new party
promoting linguistic equality and won
four seats at the national assembly
a francophone that becomes bilingual
does not weaken the french language and
culture all it does is strengthen that
individual's opportunities and horizons
for the future
though libman isn't sure the new parties
will get the traction his did he feels
lego's louisiana line gives them a boost
dan spector global news montreal
still ahead a canadian film documents a
decade of war through the eyes of syrian
refugees
[Music]
chanting ghee outside the bell center in
montreal today hockey fans lined up to
pay respects to ghee lefleur the habs
great died 10 days ago from lung cancer
visitation at the arena continues
tomorrow and the public national funeral
will be held tuesday morning in montreal
lefleur was 70 years old
for almost 50 years french has been the
only official language in quebec but two
newly formed political parties would
prefer the province become bilingual
both parties are planning to run
candidates in quebec's fall election
targeting writings with large
populations of english-speaking
quebecers such as montreal but as dan
specter reports quebec's premier is
pushing back
bourbon street mardi gras jazz music
many people see the state of louisiana
as a bucket list destination but quebec
premier francois lago sees it as a
cautionary tale
if quebec is
bilingual unfortunately the attraction
in north america to english will be so
strong that it will be a matter of time
before we don't speak french
in quebec and we become
louisiana
back when it was founded in 1718 new
orleans was known as nouvelle orleans
the capital of the french colony of
louisiana 300 years later its
connections to the french language are
mostly history french will always be
fragile in north america so we have to
protect french lago made the louisiana
comments in a week that saw the birth of
two new political parties in quebec who
unlike lagos coalition abner quebec
consider bilingualism in the province as
part of their core values you know
bilingualism you know is a bedrock idea
it's foundational to quebec one is
called the canadian party of quebec the
other is led by a former cfl player both
party leaders are trying to ride a
growing wave of anglo agitation born out
of the lego government's efforts to
strengthen legislation protecting the
french language and the sentiment that
the usually anglo-friendly liberal party
is not speaking up for the linguistic
minority anger among english speakers is
reaching heights perhaps not seen since
the 90s where now we're starting to see
similar parallels to how frustrated and
angry the community is and how much the
community feels like they're political
orphans again robert libman would know
he helped spearhead an anglo uprising in
the 90s when he founded a new party
promoting linguistic equality and won
four seats at the national assembly
a francophone that becomes bilingual
does not weaken the french language and
culture all it does is strengthen that
individual's opportunities and horizons
for the future
though libman isn't sure the new parties
will get the traction his did he feels
lego's louisiana line gives them a boost
dan specter global news montreal
still ahead a canadian film documents a
decade of war through the eyes of syrian
refugees
[Music]
it's been 10 years since civil war
forced millions of syrian refugees to
flee their homeland according to the
united nations it remains the world's
largest displacement crisis a toronto
filmmaker spent over a decade
documenting the war through the eyes of
migrant workers and as mike drollet
reports they worry the world has
forgotten them
an ask me maria a dozen years ago
lebanon's becca valley was as green and
vibrant as when filmmaker nora kovorkian
lived there as a child her documentary
batata potato in arabic was supposed to
be a love letter to her homeland and the
syrian migrant workers who helped it
flourish
until war in 2011 tore syria apart when
the revolution happened we all thought
that this is going to be maybe five
months six months and it will be crushed
and it would be the end of it nobody
expected this to be a long
refugee crisis and a civil war those
lush fields of green were soon replaced
with refugee camps and kevorkian's lens
had a new focus
you're safe at home now for a time the
world's gaze was focused on the syrian
refugees but the headlines would shift
to afghanistan and then eventually to
ukraine kevorkian had helped three
syrian families immigrate to canada but
she couldn't help them all
do they feel forgotten at this point
i think so they feel forgotten they feel
that the world has
you know moved on to more
newer refugees
refugee cases and whenever i talk to
them in the camp i keep in touch with
all the subjects on a weekly basis i
talk to them
they always say you know don't forget us
kevorkian certainly hasn't she kept
filming and waiting for a natural ending
to the story where the refugees she now
viewed his family would be able to
return home
that time has never come
and every time she's left a refugee camp
for home in canada she's been overcome
with guilt
i wasn't prepared emotionally and
psychologically
to deal with the trauma the sadness and
the difficulty of being a filmmaker on
the ground
capturing with my camera all the sadness
and
all the devastation the film is now done
and screening for festivals around the
world she kept the name patata because
the story is still about those potato
farmers stateless desperate
humbled yet hopeful their lives will
turn around
as more war creates more refugees with
every passing day
mike darling global news toronto
up next stamp of approval a unique way
to support ukraine
[Music]
back postage stamps can do a lot more
than move your mail at times they've
been used to commemorate events or
support special causes and recently
they've been generating a lot of
attention in ukraine ukrainians flocked
to the post office to buy this stamp of
a ukrainian soldier making an obscene
gesture to a russian's ship one million
were printed and they are flying off the
shelves well now a vancouver collector
is hoping to put his stamp on a made in
canada campaign paul johnson reports
i better take it otherwise i'll keep
phoning i'll come back to that sorry if
you thought the world of stamp
collecting was a sleepy backwater just
spend a while with brian duff you know
the new book on hastings mill is out now
at all nations stamps and coins in
vancouver and you may conclude otherwise
the next bid is 33. the next bid is
145. hi paul will you hold please when
we caught up with brian saturday his
phones were literally ringing off the
hook for a stamp auction the business is
alive and well
next bid is 82.50 and duff is also busy
with new ideas one of them taken
straight from the headlines as a human
i'm horrified by what's happening in
ukraine with his decades in the business
duff recalls several special issue
stamps that raised a lot of money for
charity one big hit was a u.s postal
service stamp that helped raise money
for the fight against breast cancer
so when duff saw the immediate success
of this stamp newly issued by ukraine to
capture the spirit of their resistance
against russia he got to thinking
i thought that having a stamp that would
recognize ukrainian's contribution to
canada is important at this moment in
history and i thought the canada post
has an infrastructure
where they could
provide that service
with no special connection to the
stamped visionaries at canada post duff
took to the internet and started a
change.org petition
so far a thousand people have signed on
given our close connections to ukraine
he thinks it's natural for canada to
issue a special stamp and the money he
suggests to go to the red cross
or any established charity that's
helping with refugees from the war
and with his gut instinct for things
that become valuable over time he could
be onto something incredibly the ukraine
managed to issue a million
russian warship stamps and sell them all
out instantly to people all around the
world and now they're selling for
enormous premiums in the internet
auctions
in vancouver paul johnson global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm jeff semple tonight we
leave you with commemorations in halifax
for the anniversary of the battle of the
atlantic the longest continuous campaign
of the second world war
royal canadian navy personnel and
veterans honored the sacrifices made by
thousands of canadian sailors who
ensured supplies and soldiers made it to
the front lines in europe thanks for
watching have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]